تماما راويه فامداد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
الغربيه من شانه ان يسب الزيت على نار
المواجهه بين روسيا والمعسكر الغربي فحلف
الناتو وواشنطن فعل تماما ما حذرت منهم
مرارا موسكو وهو تسليم دبابات متطوره الى
كاف وفي اول رد فعل على الخبر اكد السفير
الروسي لدى الولايات المتحده اناتلي
انتونوف ان هذه الخطوه تمثل تصعيدا خطيره
واكد ان بلاده ستقضي على جميع اسلحه
الكتله الغربيه في اوكرانيا بما في ذلك
الدبابات الامريكيه الحديثه الغضب الروسيه
بدا شديدا بعد قراري واشنطن وبرلين الى
درجه اعتبار ذلك تجاوزا للخطوط الحمراء
بهذا الخصوص قال رئيس الوفد الروسي في
محادثات فينا كونستان
ان استخدام كياف قذائف اليورانيوم من
دبابات ليوبارد سيعتبر استخداما للقنابل
النوويه القذره
منعرج جديد اذا تبلغه حرب اوكرانيا بتزويد
المعسكر الغربي
دبابات متطوره وهي الخطوه التي تعصف
بمقترحات الحل الدبلوماسي على مدى القريب
على الاقل ان وجدت ويبدو ان اداره بيدن
تدرك ذلك بل ولديها هدف ابعد فقد بدات من
الان بالتخطيط لمرحله ما بعد الحرب
الاوكرانيه وذلك من خلال اقامه توازن
عسكري بين روسيا واوكرانيا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي كشف عن الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
لنهايه الحرب الاوكرانيه والتي تقوم على
دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا من اجل خلق سلام عادل
ورغم تاكيد بلانك على ان بيد الله يتجنب
الصراع العسكري المباشر مع روسيا الا ان
واشنطن باتت ترغب في مساعدته كيف كي تكون
قادره على ردع اي عدوان في المستقبل
المفتاح هو اعطاء اوكرانيا الادوات التي
تحتاجها للدفاع عن نفسها من خلال انظمه
الاسلحه المتقدمه خاصه الدروع الجويه وهو
ما بدات فيه واشنطن من الانف ويبدو ان
اوكرانيا بدات تطمع اكثر فاكثر فوزاره
دفاعا تقول ان الخطوه القادمه هي المطالبه
بمقاتلات اف 16
[موسيقى]